we're gonna have a conversation with joe
joe good afternoon how can ken and i
help
yeah so um i'm single 21 just started
truck driving
and i had a little bit of vehicle um
problems this earlier this year
and uh so kind of what i'm thinking
right now is i'm debating between
paying to get a new vehicle or what i'm
doing right now because i only have
about three to four days home time a
month so
i'm kind of debating should i pay to get
a new car
or should i um just keep doing what i'm
doing
is uh spending money on a rental car
just while i'm home and uh you know
so i'm kind of debating between which
which is better uh in the long run
how much are you spending a month on
rental cars uh right around
um two probably 250 right around there
okay see about 250 so you're looking at
about you're spending about 24
25 hundred dollars a year on vehicles
um do you have any debt
um the only that i have is a vehicle
that i gave back
um last year i'm it was kind of upside
down in that
whole situation so got rid of that and
uh paying that off so that's about
seven thousand and uh earlier this year
i finished paying off all my credit card
so
good for you so you got seven grand on a
car
uh that's upside down and this current
car it's undrivable how much
will it cost to get repaired no he
turned it in oh he turned i'm sorry i
missed that okay you turned it in it's
not
okay so so how much are you making as a
truck driver
um usually uh it kind of depends on lows
but um right around a thousand to
1200 a week so okay uh and is that
is that uh including overtime or can you
get over time
i could get overtime yeah okay i i
anthony i'd like to see him get some
overtime he's young uh
single and now's the time to get after
it and i would go with
overtime uh to the point where you can
uh
pay off that car um and i i don't even
know if i'd rent a car i might just uber
i think
he might be able to depend on how much
he uses that car yeah
how much how much do you use that car
when you're on your two or three days
off
well being in missoula uh in montana um
everything's pretty spread out so yeah
um never mind i got it all right forget
to forget these driving around
yeah yeah so so joel i'm gonna i'm gonna
agree with ken on this one i want you to
go ahead and get some overtime man
and with your budget right now you're
pulling about four 45 to 5 000
a month regular you don't have any
expenses so i would definitely go in
ahead and just pay off this 7 000
of the debt yeah since it is a repo you
can honestly get them to talk this down
a little bit more maybe paid off for
five thousand
and then after that oh going ahead yeah
you know then going ahead and just stack
up the money
and just buy you a little cash card yeah
it's not gonna be long so i i think i'm
okay with the 200 250 marks
for the rental because he needs it right
yeah and it's only he's only for three
days yeah makes it makes no sense to go
out there and buy a car
yeah and then put insurance in that car
for it to sit for 90
days yeah i absolutely agree with you
yeah so uh you'll be all right there man
just pay it off call them
get a settlement in full letter like a
total last caller then after that stack
up about five grand a month buy you a
little beater
because you're hardly home anyways all
right